j'échoue délicieusement chaud cette
adaptation théâtrale du roman l'avalée
des avalés de réjean ducharme et aux
vieux rêve de la directrice artistique
lorraine pintal
j'en rêve depuis que j'ai 16 ans c'est
un roman qui m'a tellement marqué je me
suis identifiée à bérénice enberg donné
le roman l'avalée des avalés a été
publié en 1966 et c'est l'histoire de
bérénice heinberg une jeune fille
tiraillé entre autres par l'amour
obsessionnel pour son frère christian
est aux prises avec sa mère shamu morts
personnellement si je fais du théâtre
j'ai jamais perdu cette quête de
l'impossible et bernice en berne ne perd
jamais de vue cette quête de
l'impossible parce que l'impossible
c'est la voix de tous les possibles
cette adaptation a été joué quarante
cinq fois en europe et le met entre
autres en scène louise marleau qui s'est
sentie interpellée par l'avalée des
avalés
moi j'ai une fille alors je veux dire le
rapport avec bérénice et qui est tendue
qui est difficile je veux dire je
reconnais des moments de ma vie ou sa
peau était sain je suis un pays situé
dans ce pays que je suis se mettre en
bouche la prose de réjean ducharme n'est
pas une mince affaire
la langue est riche parfois tordu est
toujours étonnante
il faut beaucoup j'articule et que je
sorte des phrases comme on fait des
termes comme pré fall iations un
objectif qui est interne de l'ordre de
la botanique
l'adaptation théâtrale de l'avalée des
avalés sera d'abord présentée
virtuellement et si tout se met à bien
aller il pourrait y avoir une tournée au
printemps 2021
lorraine pintal a une pensée pour réjean
ducharme s'ils étaient vivants
aujourd'hui et qui apprenait qu'on peut
pas jouer devant un public
ce serait la tragédie humaine joly dit
j'en suis convaincu salée pour nous
alors ça va ça l'aurait été pour lui ici
louis fait depuis mai radio canada
montréal